[Music]
never thought of myself as being funny
anything i was associated with that
could be successful was a shock
25 years old i didn't know what i wanted
to do well what do you do when you're
talking and people are laughing
you do comedy
so i thought why not make that's a big
thought maybe i didn't put that exactly
the right way
why not me
my mother would call me up and go larry
did they like you did they tell you
you're doing a good job yeah ma they
like me the show's number one in the
country yeah but did they tell you that
they think you're doing well
i'm a total fraud
and the curb outlet for me is this guy i
want to be he's completely honest just
the opposite of who i am and it's a
thrill
i got lucky and i'll leave it at that
[Music]
there are some moments
that haunt us all our lives
moments upon which history turns
well hello my friend
what is this what have you done
welcome to the road
not
taken
do you have any idea what's happening
here
reality has been broken
there is a divergence
i know someone who could help us
understand the change in time
i'm gonna need some tea
earl grey
piping hot hello guyman
your answers are not in the stars and
they never have been
earth
2024
a single change
is vastly more dangerous than you
realize
none of our tomorrows are
we're
guaranteed
together you must bring us home
this is a very bumpy century
[Music]
but i think i'm getting the hang of it
i believe
you have one final frontier
the world works in certain ways until a
new great idea comes along and changes
everything
what if you could test your blood in
your own home
and what if it wasn't a whole vial but
just a drop
i'm going to drop out to stanford this
machine is going to change the world
these kids don't overthink they don't
get bogged down about the way things
have always been done
they want to change things now
together we are making healthcare
accessible to everyone in this country
i don't understand how you're doing this
extremely complex chemical engineering
with a high school degree
this technology is ten years away your
idea is impossible so you just keep
trying do or do not there is no try
that's yoda
okay
if you want this you have to dedicate
yourself what are you willing to do to
get it i can't give them one reason to
doubt me it's not even close to working
yet
what are we gonna show with a demo we're
gonna tell them that we don't have a
working prototype
right
our series being closed at 165 million
get the money
i know what you did at the demo the
dugout was an inspiring step forward
don't tell anyone else i'm going to
protect you this is an inspiring and
inspiring step
forward this isn't just my job this is
who i am
anybody who doubts my company
doubts me
you're ceo of a billion dollar company
what are you afraid of
her whole image is fake we have to stop
her
we haven't seen a single contract she is
lying to you
you're in over your head you're going to
lose everything
no i'm i'm fine everything's fine
you don't understand the business and
you don't understand the science
your company was endangering lives
this is your dream your story
people will trust the technology
[Applause]
because they will trust you
blackbeard captain kidd
the gentleman pirate
well the first two are like very very
talented pirates
but the last one is the scariest of them
all instead of killing with weapons he
kills with
kindness
oh right so you're the gentleman pirate
then well sussed
the rumor is you up ended your entire
comfortable life
to become a pirate
i got bad news for you genital pirate
pirating is not for everyone
it's a really dangerous lifestyle
love everyone on blackbeard huge fan sir
huge
[Music]
we're gonna go on up there and
we're gonna cause some havoc how violent
do you expect this to get
note the gusto
why'd
i'm just looting this library when i'm
replacing all the books i've looted with
ones i've already read
you know how hard it is to find someone
doing something original out here
do these outfits maybe feel like an
error in judgment it's a power move make
people feel underdressed and suddenly
you're the one in charge
you're a lunatic and i like it
we're swashbuckling we're
have fun with it
come on
give a man a warning that was your
warning
a lot of the guys are sweethearts deep
down well that's perfect they're just
dealing with a fair amount of trauma
permission to blow them to hell captain
and we're quite certain my pirates hard
to say
one appears to be a heavy set woman in a
silk dressing gown everybody hide
a gentleman never arrives empty-handed
amid tapa
toughest means little plates
yeah you know about tapas
[Music]
gamestop gamestop game stop remember
when you couldn't stop hearing about
gamestop
well thanks to a bunch of nerds on
reddit it's stock price raised to
heights no one could have ever imagined
because of all these hedge funds
shorting the stock gamestop aired off as
a undervalued player so a lot of people
are buying into it not even wondering if
they lose all their money it's more
about a middle finger to the hedge funds
there's this opportunity here to bet
against what all the hedge funds did
finally the underdogs had the upper hand
this really is taking the world by storm
oh my god it's making money let's get
these hedge fund monsters before they
get up
and that scared the [ __ ] out of some
really rich people
and then
the robin hood thing happened they cut
us off from training because they wanted
us to sell what we had what robin hood
did that took the wind out of the sails
i've never seen a here a group of stocks
that you can no longer add to there is a
lot of emotion here
all of this rage definitely the worst
point of my life
what can we do to give a voice to it the
gamestop frenzy ripped the curtain of
how rigged our markets really are they
forced the broader public to start
asking questions that they've never
really asked before and it's not just
one firm two firms three firms it's all
the firms that commit capital and that
cracked open a whole investigation wall
street has been making money out of thin
air
so that's basically stealing right
the level of illegal activity is just
astonishing
the market does get manipulated in a lot
of ways that we don't see but how do you
play a game when someone else makes the
rules someone can cheat and you'll never
know it's intentionally hidden from you
that you can't see where the problems
really lie this is our one chance to
blow up the death star
i don't even care who the whistleblower
is that's why it's important that people
come forward
this is just the beginning
carol baskin
i'm carol baskin
does the name joseph maldonado passage
mean anything to you he is a psychopath
who wishes me dead we've been in an
ongoing dispute oh it's joe
i'm sorry i understand this must be very
hard for you
oh no sorry i'm allergic to cats
[Music]
i really feel like i was put on this
earth to rescue cats welcome to
the best exotic animal show in these
united states this is who we've been
after
documented animal abuser joe exotic
we're coming for you baby i've had to
fight for everything i got i didn't even
know you had a husband almost 12 years
i come from a home
that didn't feel like a sanctuary when
there are no more animals in cages then
there will be no more need for us to
rescue them someone's got to kill that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you have no idea what i'm willing to do
for my animals i got a job for you
what kind of firearms are you looking
for something that will stop a hitman in
his tracks
[Music]
so it's war it's war
we're gonna make a family at this park
no one can say a damn thing about it
here's to the unwanted animal
it ain't just about the cats spoiler
alert
so how many people are going to see this
little documentary
you want to blow some [ __ ] up he shot me
bang bang bang three times he shot you
technically it was a blow up doll of me
we're ready to roll
this is a show i can sell this america
he's going to love you
i will never stop
if you've got any dirt on this woman i
want to hear about it he has no idea
what i've been through in my life
is this awesome or ridiculous
individually we are a whimpered
but together we are a roar
you see me now
i always thought cat people were a
little weird
[Music]
[Music]
you ever have that thing where you think
you know someone
as well as you could possibly know
anyone
and then
one day
you were totally wrong that was
something what your mom did you don't
have much time you have to leave can't
talk to anyone okay no calls no texting
nothing there are just some things
you don't understand
every time i think i get closer to
knowing her
i slipped away
we all do things we'd rather
forget mom just tell me the truth
who are you
[Music]
go the [ __ ] away
homelander what made you decide to join
up with vaughn a chance to use my gifts
to help make the world a better place
come on in not like this can look bad to
anyone i'm not a pedo by the way i don't
even have fingers i'm not a goddamn pedo
benjamin
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you guys really suck huh
[Music]
the idea is that the outer u will
finally match the inner you
picture the face you want to have
the life you want to have
just rub that all over your face
here we go
fire
[Music]
[ __ ] it
i understand your anger the violence is
never the answer [ __ ] you you
shut up
[Music]
you have any idea what a thunderclap to
the balls feels like don't be such a
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
kill me
[Music]
what'd you put in that stuff
[Music]
you helped pull me back from the
darkness
you are always with me
[Music]
it's starting
if only they knew what was coming
would be a shame for indian neighbors
became our enemies
if you only help them they're not well
the tide has turned king's counting on
you mr fraser
[Music]
all right gonna be two things at once
clear
a rebel
a loyalist
agent for the crown and an enemy of the
king
you can't live your life afraid of being
who you are
said not to know for whom the bell tolls
he tolls for thee
[Music]
you've certainly come a long way from
atm if you're to stay my word that
freezes rich is law
if america doesn't become america who
knows what that world will look like
what would that mean for a family the
clock is ticking
whoever you fight with just wait for
yourselves
i don't belong here
briana roger they don't belong here
but yet here we are
all of us
because i loved you
more than the life that i've had
[Music]
and this i promise you won't come
between us
i don't care who you are
if you're a human being
with two eyes and a heart
this game this industry
makes you feel good
[Applause]
what industry sweat socks no
show business
[Music]
hey dr bus i'm going to buy the lakers
ah no kidding welcome to sunny los
angeles great for tens time to win the
championship one of these days [ __ ] for
fans
we are trading in an empire of real
estate for what the entire league is on
the verge of bankruptcy shut up frank
dad i want to work for you all right
let's have an interview
summer draft right the lakers get top
hit right so who do i pick
it's easy
the show's stopping
naturally gifted urban magic do not use
that nickname in this house
[Music]
mama she say magic the devil's work
devil can't hoop like me though
do they even have churches in los
angeles
los angeles lakers select magic johnson
us together magic in korean oh go cream
and magic
every team's got fans we'll have
celebrities our girls they won't cheer
they'll dance
[Music]
you think i'm gonna get out there you
think it's gonna change you
i wanna build something special a real
dynasty for her outlet
ew leave the dynasties to me yo what's
up larry come on red you're afraid of
competition no but you're no competitor
from here on out
we are playing to win
[Music]
remember who you are
and where you come from
it's my family you don't have family you
have fallout
we've got a shot here to win it all you
know how rare that is
what do you want for your future
everyday
it's show time
[Music]
hey guys this move is really gonna be
great for us
probably not
[Music]
are you [ __ ] us
no we're not [ __ ] you go check it
out
welcome to shining valve really cold in
here does the heat work i mean the house
has been empty for nearly two years
she's probably not used to having people
inside of her
pat is a writer i haven't written
anything meaningful in seven years i've
been in a really dark place lately my
kids ignore me terry's at work i'm
hoping that being out in the country is
gonna help me find my muse again if we
don't get the first chapter next month i
want the advance back
no pressure
patricia
what are you doing in my house
passing ghosts not ghosts one ghost
good news they're not crazy there are
dark forces in that house
wear this metal i'm not really a sane
person put it on okay wonderful
use your words patricia
and keep it filthy that's your brand
all of a sudden i wrote 13 pages i don't
remember writing i'm good
i found my views okay put the ax down
did you write those pages we wrote them
together you wrote suck a hot dick suck
a hot dick
that was all you darling
let's get crazy
[Music]
there's a girl out there her cousin
she's the key to everything
it is time
[Music]
you know how we've been waiting for the
other shoe to drop
are you
i think it just did
russell 10 he's not just buying up
properties he's buying up people i don't
know what he has planned in this city
but i can tell it's something big
she's in danger isn't she you must
decide if you want to live she's trained
we're taking russell's hand down and
she's been waiting for this
but if you don't mind me saying probably
better not to pick fights with criminals
tan's got an army you can't stop them we
have to try
who are you i'm family kung fu new
episodes premiere march 9th free next
day only on the cw app
i'm looking for a fella carries a bowie
knife with an eye grown into the handle
[Applause]
he's back sheriff
i'll take care of it as usual
nothing to worry about just a boy with a
bag
the head weighs less than my body
the infamous red bill i told you to stab
my jurisdiction
how many men have you killed sheriff
this is my town
mine and mccoy's
we've made the rules
everything has a price
that way everything stays in balance
[Music]
we need to be on our way before someone
comes looking for that money
hello man robert bandits what's the
world coming to
it happened in greenville [ __ ] all in
the middle of nowhere so you realize
what we have to do
they're the goddamn sheriff apart
have you forgotten the vow that you made
this symbol cannot be connected to us in
any way
if you are the last man standing
promise me one thing
make sure that son of a [ __ ]
ends up in that dirty black bag
you are a gift bill
you and your beautiful
bag of heads
three
two
one
upload
i notice you're really lonely and sad
and you often express your feelings as
anger
you helen
welcome to upload your digital afterlife
uploads live a life of luxury pleasure
but they laugh something that makes
death worth living
prototypes
congrats mommy
welcome back laura anthony thanks it's
been a long time
i got so much to tell you we have one
extremely difficult camera let me speak
to a manager
what seems to be the problem you're a
[ __ ] you've been cheating now cheating
on me ingrid gave up everything and
uploaded for me i'm with someone too
i've been cheating now and cheating on
you oh
it's all good brother
that was weird so weird
uploading should be accessible for
everyone we need to hold the greedy
powerful people accountable
he likes bloody marys and the rollback
of environmental laws
well
we can handle one of those this
we're taking this place over
[Music]
thank you place your bets
[Music]
you can listen in on any upload do me
oh my god look at her she's so beautiful
anything else about me you were
considering bicep inflation a little
bigger
just a little bit
perfect
it's so ridiculous
[Music]
bridgette i'm old and i seem like i
can't remember nothing no more
i try to say what day it is
ain't got a clue
hey
so you want me to take you to that
special doctor
one of them i can help you remember
things
[Music]
can really come in later no it's just
you and me but reggie do want you to go
see this doctor so
we developed a treatment
mr gray will remember everything that he
has ever known but the treatment will
only work once
is that what you want
i got a lot of things to do
and i need my memory
to do it
there's something in your heart
mr gray how you feeling never better
that's fat
i can see it all
so clear now
my man's whole lifetime just spinning
around in there
my uncle dog stole something
treasure
i'ma find it
but
i'm worried about you the rate of the
decline is accelerating i mean in my
mind gonna be worse than it was the
folks
but i got to finish this
you got to let the river take its course
and the river know right where it's
going
[Music]
before he was an entertainment icon
dwayne johnson was a college football
standout signed by the legendary calgary
stampeders johnson you're offside i'm
not you are
it didn't go well young rock premieres
march 15th on nbc
come with me
and let's build the future
together
what do you care about
when are you happiest
make a business out of that feeling
what do you think when i say workspace
cubicles
ugly furniture bad fluorescent lighting
death
exactly
the future of work looks different we're
selling an experience
we we need a name we
we live we dream
we work
[Applause]
who wins in a fight the smart guy
or the crazy guy
are you crazy enough i may be i maybe
is adam for real i wouldn't be with him
if he wasn't the wife she works there
she helps him manifest things
we are on track to lose 400 million this
year
i think this enough adam
we're actually trapped you have to make
them see see what you're super northern
[Music]
you're afraid that he outshines you can
i get a single battle because he does
are you a maverick or a muse amuse tell
me about your goals
i want to be in vanity fair
vanity fair is not for muses
then i want to change my answer
i wanted you to meet legendary adam
newman and his wife chief branding
officer
we lease office space then we act like
we're changing the world they're turning
on you you're going to sink this [ __ ]
that's 1.9 billion losses nothing is
more important
than us i have a responsibility to think
bigger i'm a golden goose land golden
eggs you couldn't do this without me
we do this together we can change
everything
[Music]
life down on earth can be very
complicated and that's why people need
us
your team members will be hormone
monsters our divisions orgasm numbers
just came in and corporate is [ __ ]
pissed shame wizard good call mentioning
what a knockout her sister is in your
wedding test logic rocks there's no
reason to stand up yet i promise you you
will get off the plane and
many more you'll be assigned your human
clients by the tube
oh it's for
emmy i'm sorry herb
emmy what we do here is important
i get it i don't take notes i don't pay
attention i lied about my military
service
hi
i'm emmy your new love bug
holy [ __ ]
you've never done this before no wonder
i don't love this thing yes catching
what the hell are you doing here i've
won the shame lottery
praying crying grieving they're all just
pointless exercises and self-indulgence
you know peter you've got a really sassy
mouth
love lesson number one
love is a [ __ ] psycho
does it better
there's nothing better
listen it just sounds like you need a
little bit of time to reflect which is
totally fine because i just put some bar
salts up my ass and they are really
starting to kick in
what just happened you [ __ ] everything
up that's what just
i happened you connie
i love you maury
that's just the way you make me feel
that was not good very bad i
love you yeah
that's nasty yeah but we're just
immediately coming out of my mouth
[Music]
you
humanity's best weapon
master chief huh
the master chief was enhanced and
trained for one purpose
to win this war
he and the other spartans
are our only effective weapons against
the covenant
[Music]
here's lethal
upgradeable
and most importantly
controllable
covenant forces appear to be excavating
some kind of object
when i touch the object i felt something
i felt
different
what they did to us
makes you known
and you just decided to help me why
wouldn't spartan do that
what does one do with a superhuman
you're not sure you can trust
hello master chief
i'm cortana
master chief recovered something sacred
ring
halo
humans
surrendered to the covenant
cortana i'm gonna need you now
find the halo win the war
what
uh
where for will for the
if they do is it
i don't know what you're saying
higher
after this is the racism over with our
new initiative we believe racism will be
done by 2024
[Applause]
[Music]
she good
[Music]
could you please turn around
[Music]
do i gotta get naked for this
nudity isn't required i think shh i
don't know europe
[Music]
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
and people like us we don't need to walk
in our family's shadows
foreign
[Music]
sorry
foreign
[Music]
dearest gentle reader
did you miss me
as the members of our town questioned my
identity and means
this author has been doing but one thing
[Music]
honing my skills
no even better i've been sharpening my
knives
[Music]
for all of you
[Music]
hello and welcome to staying awake i
have a sleeping disorder
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
[Music]
i'm losing it
we'll catch you on
you're bloody useless
stevie stephen
[Music]
i can't tell the difference
between dreams
thank you
that's the contact lens
hope you find it
thanks
yeah oh my god you're alive what's wrong
with you mark
why did you call me mark
that must be very difficult
a voice in your head
shut up
this chaos
[Music]
embrace the chaos
[Music]
happy
you